I okay for those joining this livestream
we are talking about the D experimental
ization of experimental functions in one
language and we have a variety of topics
today as usual let's see how far we get
first up is image processing
oh boy why on earth of these things
looking so there diem boy that's a lot
of don't do experimental eyes let's talk
about all these functions
okay so image contents what's happening
with image contents we basically need to
do a training of our own we have a few
networks that are converted and we can
use some of them but the new ones like
Yolo 9000 which is classifying or
finding 9,000 classes of objects it's
not good enough that caresses are are
not as good as we want them to be we
might be able to do a combination of
those networks sooner definitely before
our own training but the end goal is to
train ourselves is what happens do we
believe there's anything in the design
of these functions that's problematic
earlier this morning Julia and I were
looking at a bunch of families that have
categories or forms and props and there
are some inconsistencies if you want to
look at them as well
we have image cases text cases that take
form goes to prop these guys takes
category comma prop then we have image
identify that this category comma n
comma proc and so forth and it would be
nice to make them consistent yes if you
recall we looked at image contents vs.
image cases text contents versus takes
cases for 12-0 and this where the design
we came up with but looking at more
functions at the same time I I think we
might be able to make them a bit more
consistent all right well schedule
something to look at that but why don't
you guys study at first and
yeah I mean what's the timescale for
doing a new training wouldn't be so
quick Julia and Jerome are gonna be
doing that
Jerome definitely needs to wrap up all
the issues with your own that framework
Giulio I think would be could be
starting that fairly soon okay and
what's a rough time so a month two
months what are we talking about I would
say maybe more in the scale of three to
six months before we have something that
can share it's not gonna be full time
but for our gathering train let's try
and get the design aspects of this clean
and let's make a big table of all of our
mm you know text audio image I don't
know and cases itself and so on yes yes
because okay string cases I didn't have
all add that to my list of any other
cases functions that are I'm forgetting
well we have with cases comes deleting
traces sequence cases is one speech
cases goes with text cases
um
you
you
Wow
in some bizarre way with argument null
and null is not a valid link object this
is running the latest 12.1 so somebody
should report that Raj that's for you
yep also this the fact that it now
whatever um okay all right oh these are
all in the same bucket yes except for
image pyramid which is a completely
different thing I mean I have no idea
about image pyramid why do you want to
add some I don't understand
the fact that you want to add random
functionality it's not a reason to not
the experimental eyes this but I have no
idea I mean I've never used this so I
can't really comment on whether it's you
know on how useful it is and and whether
this is the correct design I think the
design is correct for what we have
implemented so far the type which is the
same second argument could be extended
to accept more types like steerable
arrays and so forth
and and at that time maybe then the
properties wouldn't be correct but I'm
not even keen on pushing all of them
into the same function maybe they could
be separate function oh for goodness
sake well as far as I'm concerned you
know this is not something I've never
used it did does any other system
function use it yeah this is the logic
and for dynamic image for instance
okay are we using it and we're using it
from maps as well no not this one maps
are mainly taking tiles at be given at
the requested resolution or zoom level
but we also discussed within ourselves
and with the front-end team to
potentially improve the typesetting of
image objects especially if we start
looking into out of core image or even
inquire images in order to make the
image typesetting a bit more lightweight
it would be nice if we don't show all of
the image pixels at the first go and
just just show as much as we need in a
notebook yes like for instance I can use
some image pyramid technology underneath
I would be interesting okay but so is
the design that we have here
ergonomically I mean as you try to use
it is this does it seem to work nicely
definitely all of those just need
Gaussian permits
it's just down sampling so I don't
understand if I make an image pyramid
here okay so let's say I make an image
pyramid and then the use that you've
given is a pure down sampling use yep
right so so what you're storing like in
the file or something is okay so how do
I get that picture at a certain sample
level so in here it's by some value so
Pierre part one Pierre part - okay
butBut but what I want to know is let's
say I want image size 30 by 30 that's
inverse image pyramid okay
so you're saying if I do this
you
well that's not what I'm asking for I'm
asking for I want to give an image size
here mm-hmm so yeah the only thing that
is in the way is that type that you
don't care to specify
bad design I mean look the factors for
the use case you're describing let's
talk about the packaging that would
actually be useful for this what you're
basically saying is this is some kind of
multi scale image mm-hmm and I don't
care that it's an image pyramid or an
image you know diamonds or anything all
I care about is that what I'm gonna get
is a you know a multi scale image which
I can then actualize as an image of a
certain resolution all right so in other
words what I would like is to be able to
say from a high-resolution image it's
like you know I could say something like
you know multi scale image I don't know
this isn't the right thing but but that
then is the multi scale image and then
to get it a certain image image size I
just ask it for that image size right
and then I get an image of that size
that size so still you can do it with
that last syntax of image inverse image
pyramid yeah but it's yes Gaussian and
then whatever a hundred okay but that's
silly
oh no that that that takes it as n as
the level and so so yep
okay so then
all right I mean this is typical sort of
hostile not okay so that those are
larger that that initial image is small
so you just don't get it larger it
doesn't
but it should
look the fact is we should have a
function that simply multi scales is a
multi scale image where I mean we have
ways of up sampling using machine
learning stuff right or the classical
stuff yeah how would we up sample this
thing just image resize mm and you
increase the number of pixels
and not the pyramid but that result
that thing here yep
image resize of that comma what mm that
you asked for
and then the pixel dimensions of that is
going to be mm
you
you
you
that's pretty nice that's pretty nice
not bad at all yep okay so let's talk
about how to package this
okay cuz what you're describing is
perfectly useful
it's basically storing an image in a
multi scale form so that it can be
readily you know retrieved at a
particular size so I mean for example
having image size be able to eat image
pyramids seems like it will be useful
mm-hmm well for that we also have the
image pyramid apply where we apply a
function to every you know I don't care
I don't care what wit look you're
telling me the actual use of this is to
store multi scale images let's make it
easy we're not applying any image
pyramids to anything we're just
providing some something which is a
multi scale image and that's it you know
the simple thing right so the question
is only you know when we get an image we
could decide to multi scale it yep and
then the different things that use it
like the front end for example can
simply request it at different
resolutions yep what I'm saying so I
mean it's even possible given a
resolution higher than they originally
provide that sample why not why not
seems like a good idea to me I mean why
not we've got the technology why not do
it you know why have something pixelated
when we don't need to
so the question is how do we package
this and how does it relate to the image
object itself
so I'm saying yep
because I think it's very useful to have
an image object which has a known number
of pixels and so on
and it's possible that we should
introduce something called multi scale
image which would be
I don't know I don't know because I mean
if you do an image processing operation
on a multi scale image like an edge
detect or something clearly it cares
about the actual individual pixel level
yes and the question is how to deal with
that in a multi scale image oh it's what
size it assumes that the thing is
um well this for a separate meeting but
the packaging we need because this is
what will actually make this useful and
I don't really care about the you know
the underlying image pyramid is for
image processing experts yep
and potentially useful but but not but
the really killer thing is as you say
being able to have something where the
actual display I mean clearly if we
wanted to right now we could down sample
images for display and you know I mean
we could have perfectly well inside
image we could have an image display
function which down samples the image
you see what I'm saying
just four types in II yep like manage
size said no not just four types of me
no no four type setting okay
yes and which display function that that
could be image resize and I mean that we
could implement right now right so it's
a unfortunate I mean I don't know how
fast image resizes but that will be an
interesting thing to look at right now
okay now the question is when you
typeset something like that if what
matters is the number of pixels I don't
even know what really matters
it's what's stored in the notebook that
matters is that true that's definitely
yeah that's definitely important well
but but I mean then the question is the
high-resolution image where does it go
and when you resize it is it using more
image data than it was using I don't
know we have to look at this okay so get
a meeting together about this and about
image display function multi scale image
and how its rendered in the front end
maybe you can have one without me we're
going to start with okay no we have
started that discussion it's just okay
in addition why don't you figure out
what actually makes sense for the image
pyramid functions given that you're
basically telling me their arguments are
in the wrong order
not quite but okay I'll look at that
again and see if we can really move
arguments around also I think for that
image display function we already have
image preview function which we use an
image capture maybe that could be used
as a what is it much preview that's
that's exactly it's it's for image
capture when you're getting images from
a camera image preview function is oh I
see I see
yeah changing there that's a good idea
yeah yeah right that's a good idea
okay facial features why on earth we
want to keep this experimental
I mean it works quite well I don't
understand why we want to have this be
experimental
did you see the comment yeah I don't
care I mean yes we could always make a
better thing
okay so I'm saying I mean III don't see
why this is some
I mean are we happy with all these names
then let's make it an experimental okay
so this one we went through that very
painful design review about this
did we resolve everything that needs to
be resolved like how to get back a
cellular automata object and things
there is still work to be done but I'm
with what we agreed on last time I'm
still happy to do experimental this one
probably more elements are gonna come
down the road this is still not
reflecting what we discussed last okay
fun sounds fun to me okay
image graphics
well is the functionality here
I mean if I take a random image let me
just get an image here
all right I'm going to scream capture
something
you
well actually we could take the horse
but I'm gonna take this thing instead
okay
you
you
okay now what did that just do
what did it do
what this just did because that looks
like an image still
you
what do you mean well what is this thing
so basically this should be a graphics
okay but what it's doing it's creating
polygons around those lines currently as
as the comment says there is no
heuristic for finding thin objects and
then approximating them well okay so
look at that this isn't bad
but you think those are all polygons
they are all polygons now yeah
graphics complexes as you saw them but
we think we should be able to identify
thin objects in an in an image and then
approximate them with lines and Bezier
curves and so forth instead with the
proper thickness well that seems much
more useful yep and then I think with
that addition potentially their care and
argument set up is not going to work
well as far as design let me take a look
so how does this relate to
um particle mesh graph or something
where you can take an object and
decompose it I mean like for example
I could imagine an image graph
function2 that would take that's more
ornate we we do have morphological graph
which takes a binary image of a skeleton
like that I
I suggest you binarize and negate that's
what morphological graph is going to
expect
you
yep
okay
you
I wasn't totally shabby
about at all
the nodes well you can style them to be
bigger but they currently look small and
black to me
are all the notes okay so let me just do
what do I say if I say graph % vertex
style yep
our Oh large and red does that not work
I don't see any vertices there do we
have the right-click menu on that graph
oh but do a vertex count the graph
without the vertex yeah then do orange
well let's take a look score vertices
all right why aren't we seeing them yep
why aren't we seeing that why are we not
seeing them those are the black ends of
those lines look but look okay but then
why didn't this vertex style work
dad I don't know I have a bad feeling
I know what's happened the reason is
that this thing I took it's an
interesting bug so the issue is that
this
um it is looking at the nearest vertices
to decide the vertex size okay it
shouldn't do that in this case the words
when it should be setting that so that
you can see the vertices even though
some of the vertices that have been
identified are very nearby do you get
what I'm saying yes because otherwise it
was rescaling the point size down okay
so let's take a look at this function
again
oh yeah that's really not the right
thing it really is much more like a mesh
components type thing where you say find
me all the polygons find me all the
lines points whatever else I think so I
think we want that to take an objective
rather than well but I understand but I
mean it's I think what is it called
graphic smash what is it called
mesh
which conversion are you looking for I'm
looking
no but I'm looking for more than that
I'm looking for the thing that turns
these into a mesh of a certain dimension
um I just used this yesterday um fact I
just uh um what is it
gosh
you
you
oh boy um
boundary discretized graphics
you
you
mesh connectivity graph things like this
okay and so I
say so that too is giving me let's say I
say a ball here
why does it do that
oh I need to say discretize graphics
or discretize region I think oh boy now
let's just do graphed odds of that so
that should be a filled in ball with
122,000 edges if the thing will plot
okay but you see that that too is
somehow giving it's taking connectivity
between in other words I think there's a
there's a sense in which we we need to
give a target several of these functions
have this concept of a target
dimensionality the thing we're looking
at yes
it's kind of interesting to see what it
did here okay so it's a three
dimensional that's there all of them Wow
if I done as a sphere it would have been
a little bit more civilized magnificent
um a diatom would be proud to have that
as its aluminosilicate skeleton or
something
never mind okay yeah maybe it wouldn't
maybe it wouldn't I don't know if that's
what it needs but okay um okay in any
case that's what I would do for that but
I mean one question is the high DPI
project did it successfully use image
graphics or not did they try
um I don't know the asset updates you
mean yes I don't know why don't we ask
them I mean for example the use of image
graphics for that whoops for that very
logo there which is a bitmap right yes
so I mean an interesting question is
what would it do
on that very logo
well again I don't have high hopes for
image graphics because those are lines
all right do we and algorithmically yeah
so it's really hopeless we understand
algorithmically what to do it's
magnificent polygon work but not useful
no algorithmically what to do yep okay
can you describe it well as I said we
should approximate objects of the same
width all along so in this case for
instance we have one or two pixels rough
the area I understand that's a good idea
right yep that's a good idea and there's
also the question of when is a line a
straight line yes what heuristics are we
going to use for that
and when is a line okay look the things
we've got a certain primitives like when
is a circle a circle now
this seems to me it it it relates to the
diagram OCR project that we have
I agree yes I have been out of that for
a while I probably attended one meeting
who's involved with that I thought
Michael I'm not sure anymore
okay I mean because there's that let's
find out what's happening with that and
let's see if we can merge these two
things
I mean clearly there's a there's an
aspect of diagram OCR which isn't OCR at
all which is that we give people drawing
tools on the web and they draw things
and then that's not OCR but this is
genuine OCR this would be a really nice
thing to have to be able to take our
primitives like lines and and you know
beyond that it's like is it a triangle
is it a polygon right yep
Wow that would be really nice to have if
you can deliver that that would be have
a lot of use in a bunch of things that
were planning for Wolfram Alpha math
content and so on okay dynamic image
so the use of image pyramid is one thing
yes but what's the backing for dynamic
image it's it's a it's a file is that
right or an ink or image object either
one
okay okay do we think the UX of this is
is adequate
I haven't use easy assets are mostly
shake except from what we call a zoom
bar there scrolling bars on the sides
that can also be used for zooming you
see the knobs at the ends of those
scroll bars those can be dragged and
zoom that that's something we invite
weird okay very good
could you show this to Noah who's
working on the toolbar
so apart from that other assets are
shared between dynamic image and dynamic
dynamic Geographics we never really
continue discussing dynamic graphics or
other dynamic objects we need to have
dynamic graphics that that should be
something for Bret's agenda okay it we
need it we needed it for a long time I
mean it needs a recompute function and
that's what's tricky but I think we
should be able to do it right um
even without a recompute function it's
already useful I mean like it with an
image you clearly can't you know well we
could use machine learning to do
something insane but we can't zoom out
to the point where we see more apples
than they took in the photograph types
right yeah
um I mean we could do some crazy machine
learning thing just for entertainment
value but that's not genuinely useful
someone on our live stream is commenting
on the point cloud to 3d object thing
and that is an interesting question to
what extent image 3d and image 3d
graphics thing is possible now either
region image image not image graphics
region image image mesh those are the
pair of functions that can go from image
to region the region image basically
converts a region to a to an image or
image 3d well which one image region
region image image image region is an
option oh boy an old option oh boy
that's a mess
you claim
that we approve that having the that's a
really bad idea
having region image beep no didn't even
work takes a region what was that was so
it's these image of a region that's
correct
how do I get a region from an image
image mesh
and that only works with binary images
again
okay now what about 3d works works as
well with binary image 3ds so for
example let me show you an example ah
you get one here
you
okay I will
something
um which I conveniently happened down in
my session hopefully okay see that thing
okay
our mission is to reconstruct that as a
surface okay so if I do list surface
plot that's what I get now you're
telling me that there's a way to take
that object well I've got the 3d points
for that thing I
graph embedding them that's the set of
3d points so how would I turn that into
if I take that those 3d points and I
want to turn it into let's say I want to
make those points larger and turn the
results into a region and how do I do
that
turn it into an image 3d
no I mean so like I can say list point
plot 3d of this thing presumably
it's probably imagine how long it's
going to take but it's okay there's the
point cloud
okay okay so my challenge now is to
reconstruct a surface from that point
cloud
so I'm saying
Oh or to reconstruct so how should I do
that
we should be able to rasterize that to
an to a 3d image and do some stuff
morphologically and threw in there on
the volume to clean up fill the holes
and things like that but they don't
think that's that's the proper way of
doing this you really somehow want a
manifold around it if you really want
your surface I think so but not I mean I
conclude get the convex hull and things
like that but I would like to get
something that is some you know the best
reconstruction that we can get of a
manifold mm-hmm from this
nothing comes to mind immediately with
the stuff that we have now with image
graphics we have a bunch of that when it
comes to smoothing the polygons okay but
but I mean in in um in 3d what about a
3d no mostly in 2d
so a three DML okay but but but we can
also think about image graphics working
on an image 3d I'm turning it into 3d
graphics primitives yes
which will be interesting I mean most
image 3ds I don't know what to what
extent the scanners successfully produce
image 3d objects
I mean DICOM certainly can make an image
3d object mm-hmm
so if we want to make you know your
picture of your average bone or
something as graphics primitives we
would need that yep I think that's
definitely gonna have the the mechanics
of going from a set of points to a
manifold is definitely useful in in
various places yeah I mean I've tried on
things related to this I've tried a
variety of algorithms for manifold
finding and they've all produce garbage
mm-hmm I mean you know that may not be
surprising given where this comes from
so almost so pyramids image graphics
dynamic image all of those are markets
and we'll have to prioritize what goes
first including image stitching better
image align reconstruction of 3d objects
from point clouds which is this yes
so does Marcus think he has algorithms
for doing that yeah there are algorithms
proposed out there for things like that
as you said not all of them work great
but we should start I'd be interested to
know what Marcus has to say about this
one why don't we send him this one um
how do I send this to him I could just
put pushes to the cloud oh actually
somebody else to Sushma she can find
this it's owned them
um I'd really be interested know what he
has to say about this whether he thinks
that any any manifold algorithms let's
see whether I can let me just say this
sub how can I give this term in a
reasonable way I think this is fairly
big that's the problem let's look at the
halong sirs
oh it's not that bad actually
alright here I'm going to just
you
use our technology
and then
got that URL the fact that there isn't a
URL
extractor for cloud object is really
annoying okay I will send that to you
for Marcus and I would like his comments
on it um I may have to be a permissioned
for him I'll send it also copy to Sushma
she accept that
I can probably do this permissions oh I
don't know how to do it um okay let's
continue help zoom Center what is that
about that's an option of dynamic image
that's the initial center of dynamic
image same with zoom factor whatever
some venetian who knows what that's
supposed to be okay alright that's it
for your section experimental yes yes
yes yes it is because it needs to be
part of the dynamic graphics family and
we should have a meeting to discuss it
okay
all right base and code base decode I
forgot it why are we keeping these
experimental what's wrong with you yes
yes thank you very much shadi
thank you lots of wonderful nationality
okay what is wrong with base encoding
base decode we've only implemented one
base and so the design for actually
having multiple bases or even you know
basics t4 but with different right
because they're multiple standards is
very unclear so so until we actually
have more than one base I thought they
were okay fair enough I thought there
were things like base aren't there like
base eighty and base whatever else there
is base eighty-five so wxf implements
but it's not exposed to through base
decode base 64 a base 85 and I feel like
something else which I why don't we dig
why aren't we exposing them for a bit
foot and base encoding base decode
because we haven't had a developer to
work on it I mean Dorian would sort of
be the natural person so if we can tap
Dorian to do that is it easy I think it
should be pretty straightforward okay if
he can do it in half a day he should do
it otherwise he should not do it okay so
right and of course there are sort of
multiple different versions of each
bass right depending on whether you
insist on padding and you know there
might be multiple alphabets etc so we
would need to design like we would there
was all just be sort of different named
formats I think they would just be named
I think this is just a zoo this is just
a zoo with specific animals in it not I
don't know what the generalization of a
zoo with parametrized animals is but I
don't think those exist um sorry no I
mean it's just it's just a thing with a
specific collection of you know of
creatures I think because that's what's
useful if somebody says I've got this
base 85 encoded thing can you decode it
now I don't know what the relationship
is between these and and import formats
I mean is there some sense in which we
can say there's a base64 import format
that is a file you know does that make
sense
there is a basic C for there already is
a basic C for import format it's kind of
weird because I think it tries to then
it's sort of ambiguous what exactly it's
trying to do and I think it's trying to
import it and then you know decode it
and then import it as an expression
which sometimes surprises people
oh yeah kind of horrify me because
that's a different thing that's you know
that's like but the import elements what
the default import element is should be
discussed discussed look let's talk
about this in an LCC meeting and get
durian there and let's talk about what
these various decode and code things
should be in their relationship to
import-export okay but I agree that I
mean the only thing I would say in terms
of the experimental icing is if we're
pretty certain that the default is going
to be base64 I mean it's not gonna be
one of those things where in five years
there's a different obviously is it
um hey we got bunch of background noise
here um I don't thinks I mean right we
could debate of whether the specific
base64 we have implemented is too
rekt base64 oh gosh is other variants
yes there are variants a gun ahve decode
are they discoverable or are they not
discoverable or are they only
heuristically discoverable it's been a
while since I looked at that so I can't
tell you I well maybe maybe on the
decode front they're all they're all
discoverable it may be that in the end
code right like the end code because
some of it has to do with padding and
things like that which I think you know
decode will just ignore or not ignore in
the padding okay ah like I said it's
been through a lot and take a look at it
let's discuss it in the LCC meeting okay
um alright let's briefly look at channel
stuff this Jessie here
and they sign of Jessie see I'm right
here sir okay great um well it says keep
experimental for everything but what is
the status of all of this uh this is
this is basically done on the client
side the reason I suggested to keep
everything experimental was because
there are some necessary minor but
necessary possibly breaking changes that
have been made to the design and didn't
seem right to be experimental eyes at
the same time that those those
potentially breaking changes are being I
think what others what are those changes
and what are they what is all this stuff
I don't even know what I don't even
remember this at all the channel data
been oops
does it have option to channel listen
which feeds channel content into a data
bit gosh I didn't even remember that we
had that so I mean all of this
complexity here and things like the
channel pre send function and so on is
this does this all make sense or not um
by and large it makes sense there are
that there's a particular set of
functionalities the handler functions
thing and pre send function is related
to that which are things that I think
would be would be good to get rid of in
the long run the way that those work is
the when you create a channel listener
you can have a Karl back it's just the
second argument to channel this and that
gets executed locally
every time a message comes in but
handler functions are pieces of code
they're actually attached to the channel
on the server and then everyone who
listens to the channel gets that code
running on their on their client
whenever a message comes through so it's
a callback that's part of the channel
but that runs locally okay the the the
hand that the use of handler functions
and things like sessions submit is well
established and I don't establish things
still experimental that just seems
bizarre to me well okay yeah I guess
that hand that handler functions and all
that here that it's the generic
specifically
in channel framework that I think I yeah
I understand but I don't notice my
handler functions are still experimental
to begin with and Roger I don't know
whether that's on your list but it
should be I mean that that just seems
like it yeah it seems crazy Roger still
with us yeah yeah yes okay
um
all this mechanism that is primarily
security stuff for channels does it
actually make sense or is it all crazy
the security stuff is specifically
because the handler functions thing is a
it's a security flaw so we if we have to
basically disabled by default that's
what that dollar allow external channel
functions is for but does it sensible I
mean does anybody care I mean it
basically allows you to run upon receipt
of data on a channel you can run
something on the client side right yes
those want care
I mean well once one certainly wants to
be able to do that I don't think one
necessarily wants that code to be
attached to B Channel the server side
representation of them in other words
what another approach would be that
there's simply a packet that defines
certain standard channel handlers and
those are all you get and those just
part of the system and they have the
same security as the system
rather than a user being able to define
a in other words one could make people
download the channel handler independent
of the channel just say you want to use
this type of channel download this
channel handler from this place
so to speak or it's part of the system
rather than the thing is kind of
bootstrapping itself from the channel
itself
yes yeah I'm not sure I would I would
take that specific approach but in the
example of like the the system that we
have for the live coding competition the
code that runs locally is part of this
live coding packet that that among other
things just called this channel listen
with the second argument that's a
callback
which is but but it the delivery of the
code that is going to be in the core but
so the thing that is the security hole
or the security problem is a channel
reaches out to you and says connect to
me I'm I'm a happy Channel but it's in
fact a fish so to speak because the
channel itself contains code that
automatically runs yes yeah that's a
disaster essentially yes why are we
doing yes this just seems pointless I
mean it seems like the only case where
that would be relevant is if assume that
you had no communication
I mean the only way I can imagine doing
that is of a channel tries to connect
and it literally prompts you for
you know do you want to run this code
yeah I mean that would be okay and then
we don't need this whole elaborate
system for preventing I mean how much
sandboxing is it sandboxing that code
anyway or not now
I probably can't because it has to be
able to do all kinds of things yes so I
mean it seems like the correct design is
if a channel contacts you and says I
want to monkey with your system and it's
going to be this piece of code then you
separately say okay great either approve
it for you or download it I think it'd
be a lot better if the code was somehow
visible rather than just trust me I'm a
you know in other words because because
the code is perfectly readable in most
cases well at least it conceptually so I
don't know it just seems like the wrong
way to do it well I I've never I've
never thought of or seen a a reasonable
realistic application where it's
actually necessary that that code be
transmitted in band at all fair enough
I mean it kind of makes a cool demo but
that's that's all
yeah well but it doesn't matter I mean
if if in band look okay okay the obvious
thing to do this was not probably
thought through but the obvious thing to
do is in band simply transmit a message
that says run this code to download the
client you need because I mean if at the
very beginning if right at the outset
well okay so I'm imaginated in the chat
kind of way of doing it and I guess
there's a notion of a channel that is
purely
that's an autonomous channel that
doesn't involve a human ever seeing
anything what examples do we have of
that we have various password exchange
things and so on yeah go ahead what
um I the only thing I can think of is
whatever is being done in the the
service service object service connect
ecosystem I think they do something with
the channel framework and I meant to ask
that I haven't yet it's Christian on the
school he might filter what so what we
use the channel to for the oil can
technical indications so in case if
general is working correctly do you just
get the service website in your browser
you authenticate and then get back to
you open language if the channel is down
we have a fallback method where you have
to copy and paste some IDs right but so
what's happening is can you just explain
that plumbing I mean you're you are
calling let's say Facebook oh so hard
maybe Facebook didn't even have these
anymore but it's for the authentication
of an external API
what what do you give to what how do you
do this how does it work I don't know
the exact details okay fine Oh fine um
because I think what it's doing is it's
going to that website but it's then
giving that website a call back you know
a pub/sub call back so to speak so that
when it delivers the authentication
token that is needed that is transmitted
through a channel to our to the URL
specified in the channel to the channel
broker URL so that we can pick up that
authentication token without you having
to copy/paste it okay yeah I think I got
it it's like three-legged OAuth when
there's a user in the loop or a browser
in the loop I Christian I I will I will
want to look at that to make sure that
it it still works as these changes
because the like channel URL the idea
then they're actually being an HTTP
endpoint that you can post to to send do
channel does that does not exist anymore
so if it's actually doing that some
changes well but that should happen like
lickety-split cuz yeah I know um okay I
don't know whether the testing ROG
that's a question for you whether the
testing protocols for authentication of
external API is how that's working that
seems tough to do automated testing on
yeah I always had problems with you know
with testing all these all these
external protocols like we try to bake
keys in in the code like we look at the
internal variables and try to set set
what what keys you get but but yes I
mean it always freaks and it it isn't
the easiest at least thing to automate
right well I mean I I think it's
sounding like from the change that jesse
is talking about you better do a round
of testing on those things because and
how we can automate them I mean I mean
between web execute and other things
it's conceivable that they could be
automated although it just seems like a
horrifying moving target because it
depends on the specific details of the
login dialog
of different term you know random
websites and things seems completely
horrifying okay so look Jessie the you
know I think it'd be worth having a
discussion about what the channel
framework looks like if there is no
security issue if there's no weird in
other words so for example if it can
have if the channel action right if if
in other words let's imagine that it had
five named actions it could take is that
realistic when are those named actions
things that we've predefined I don't
know what they are but things where you
can be sure that the remote control of
your machine is not going to do anything
horrifying because those are simply
predefined actions that have been you
know vetted right those are not
arbitrary code actions those are actions
that involve I don't know what you know
notebook put of some particular thing or
some such other piece okay I'm I'm
curious about what those might actually
be is awful so I honestly can't think of
anything that would be used tool for
realistic uses of this well what about
the simian framework the streaming
framework has a client right
yes okay so whatever that client is is
one of those actions I would think
or am i confused yeah that's it's theirs
it shouldn't be it shouldn't be part of
it shouldn't be associated with the
channel I mean the notebook streaming
stuff is going to be a bunch of a bunch
of client-side code and in a packet that
among other things among various
front-end stuff happens to do a create
channel a channel this in a channel send
somewhere in its and it's it's it's
machine and but making that whole thing
a part of the of the channel or a piece
of code that is that is somehow
intimately associated with the channel
seems like backwards way to design it
fair enough okay so either the channel
is it's like a file or something a
channel is just like a generic transport
layer exactly it's a transport layer and
there should not be code directly
associated with that with that transport
layer inside I mean the weird thing is
that this channel framework originally
had the notion of a channel could reach
out and tell a remote system what to do
which just seems totally wrong
but right and if I really want to do
that you can write it yourself you can
you can you can you can do that yourself
we're not preventing you from doing it
right but I mean you're like let me give
an example so so discovery for remote
kernels is that relevant our channels
relevant to that discovery process
so for example if I
if I have a broadcast if I want to know
I've got some random machine
and the question is are there available
remote kernels to run on that machine
yeah I I can't see how channel framework
would be relevant to that or could ever
be relevant to that with what it's with
what it's designed to me I mean you need
that's that's like multicast DNS the
sort of thing yes yes there's the the
Venn diagram circles do not overlap
between channel framework and and any
kind of discovery thing i what about I
was looking at various concurrent
programming things like an Erlang they
have some primitive which is some kind
of registry for externally spawned for
for programs that spontaneously spawn
themselves on remote CPUs that then
register to let so that other programs
can know that they exist is there
something relevant to the channel
framework in that well okay yeah you
know you could you could implement now
that I just thought about a little bit
more but you you could implement this as
a discovery thing if you have all of
these kernels that you're if you have
all of these kernels that are available
to be discovered listening on on some
channel and then your discovery machine
sends a message to that channel saying
who's who's who's accessible who's there
and then all of those that are there
send back a message saying I'm here
here's my IP I guess but yeah you could
do that so this is some hailing
frequency concept before yeah yeah but I
mean even if they do say that here's my
IP is that supposed to be a public IP
that's accessible over the Internet
I mean you could do it whether you'd
want no I'm sure that you need to have
some crypto you know protocol that
involves I mean I don't know what
exactly happens but but yeah it would
need to be some multi legged OAuth
creature that can take right because
there's there's you there's the machine
I don't immediately see how to do it but
you get what I'm saying that you need to
have somehow I mean if you just go to
some random person's machine and start
you know
looking around and seeing where there's
anything runnable that's just completely
crazy but assume that there has been
some authentication transaction that
happened well sure I mean access to
channels can be controlled via our
permissions mechanisms you can say only
these will because I write so that they
are they proxied through the clouds
permission mechanism not not on every
request when you when you connect to the
channel broker you send along your
current cloud
oh I'll token and the broker checks that
on your on connect against the against
the cloud and cloud says yeah that's
that's valid this person is who they
claim to be or not and if they are who
they claim to be for that session you
are you the channel broker says okay you
are you're Jesse you can do whatever any
any channel that says Jesse can can
access it you're allowed to yeah okay I
think we are out of time here but I
would like to Jesse maybe you can set up
or we can get set up a meeting to talk
about the channel framework and its uses
given that you've now apparently got the
I mean is the MQTT server now in
production or not still not yet no still
still not yet I I was wrapping up the
client because of the code freeze
deadline on that but but they had be
MQTT server is very close to finished
it's just I mean it's just um
deployment things that are left like
getting the database working in a
clustered environment and what is the
throughput that we expect for the MQTT
server is it huge I I don't I don't have
a good number on that because I've had
difficulty doing doing good load testing
but it's I mean it's significantly
better like channel send send and listen
actions are on the order of like eight
times speed they they were on the old
server yeah but the question is really
throughput them and coming in at about
through this thing well I'll get back to
you as soon as I'm I'm hey I'm able to
distance and gigabytes I mean the
bottleneck for load testing ends up
being like you're local
network connection and connecting to the
to the server it's and it's on my to-do
list to do decent load testing it's just
I just had these difficulty with it so
far
fair enough um okay sounds good
all right we should wrap this up here
thanks guys um it is one of these days
Raj will have one of these two
experimental ization meetings where we
just go through and and hit the I didn't
even realize that these things actually
go green that's very cool feature I want
to do more of that
um but it's still useful to understand
where we're at with these functions um
very good thanks a lot thanks to folks
on the livestream as well see you all
soon